un tableau et qu'elle secrétaire la vie
syndicale du bureau national du snj cgt
bonsoir pablo et qu'elle merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france donc
avait une table ronde organisée cet
après midi autour de ce code comment ça
s'est passé qu'est ce qui est ressorti
bonjour merci pour l'invitation ça s'est
bien passé et ce qui est ressorti c'est
qu'il ya un constat partagé sur une
situation problématique en france
compréhension de de ce que c'est le
journalisme comment le journalisme peut
s'exercer et que nous devons avancer et
travailler ensemble parce qu il y a
plusieurs un groupe ou organisme ou
organisation qui font chacune des
comptages de leur côté ce serait bien
que je travaille ensemble pour répondre
au gouvernement ou pour alerter le
gouvernement que la situation ne devrait
plus continuer alors vous parlez
d'incompréhension quelle est elle
précisément cette incompréhension je
pense qu'il y en a plusieurs mais une
des première c'est que le gouvernement
enfin
le ministre
christophe castaner a répondu à pierre
laurent en décembre dernier sur la
question de quel sont les journalistes
qui peuvent couvrir les manifestations
comme ans reconnaît les journalistes
professionnels de ceux qui s'habillent
journalistes et qui ne le sont pas et
voilà notre intention aussi cgt en
invitant à l'itie pmf et et
et la fédération européenne des
journalistes c'était de dire et redire
que le journalisme est un métier de
libre exercice et que donc tout le monde
pouvait travailler toutes personnes
servant d'écran journalistes pouvaient
travailler en manifestation et donc
voilà il fallait qu'on travaille
ensemble pour peut être identifiés et
c'est bien mais qu' il ne pouvait pas y
avoir une considération par rapport à
statut professionnel qui est quelque
chose qui relève plus du code du travail
en fait que quelqu'un ait ou pas une
carte de presse et ça la représentante
du du snj national dominique pradalié
par exemple a insisté pour dire voilà ce
n'est pas au gouvernement la police de
dire qui est légitime ou pas pour courir
une manifestation clairement quels sont
les socios les solutions concrètes qui
sont ressortis de cette table-ronde
aujourd'hui et surtout proposé par ce
code des solutions concrètes
aujourd'hui c'est difficile tant qu'il
n'y a pas de dialogue de vrais dialogues
où les gens s'écoute s'entendre
aujourd'hui en france ce dialogue et
n'existe pas on n'a pas de réponses ou
des réponses à peu à côté de la plaque
de la part du du gouvernement et avec
les syndicats de police évidemment inc
il y a aujourd'hui pas de dialogue ce
qui est intéressant c'est s'il ya une
solution
le le représentant de la police belge
qui qui qui est aussi délégué d'europe
le disait s'il n'y a pas de dialogue
c'est difficile de trouver des solutions
et et dans d'autres pays un petit peu en
allemagne mais déjà aux pays bas un peu
plus il montre que les échanges la
formation
croisé que les journalistes soient
formés au travail de la police que les
policiers soient formés au travail des
journalistes
ce sont des solutions intéressantes mais
je pense que nous on est très loin et
qu'un premier pas serait de le renvoyer
ce code de la liberté de la presse pour
la police aux préfets dans les
départements au ministère au sein d'êta
de policiers pour qu'on commence à se
parler parce que constat difficile alors
parmi les participants il ya le
journaliste controversé un tas boivent
sens et celui d'ailleurs qui a tweeté
que macron étaient présents au théâtre
ce week-end avec ce qui en a suivi est
ce que c'est une bonne façon pour vous
d'établir le dialogue avec le
gouvernement
avoir ce genre de membres finalement
parmi vous est ce que c'est pas contre
productif
non pour moi 1re contraire c'est
justement un soutien de la profession
boire d'une partie de la forte
profession mais d'une grande partie de
la profession qui est représenté par par
les syndicats donc aussi bien le samedi
que le snj cgt soutiennent que pour nous
un tas aboaf n'est pas un journaliste
controversé ne pas journaliste militant
n'est pas un journaliste avec un
adjectif
il est journaliste et en france
aujourd'hui il a parfaitement le droit
d'exercer comme un journaliste pour un
média pourquoi quelqu'un qui
travaillerait chez vous crtc réalise les
questions et nous attaquer et quelqu'un
qui travaille
l'opinion ou quelqu'un qui travaille aux
échos voilà et les explications qu'il a
données moi je trouve très intéressante
parce que ça va au délà juste de
l'application de la loi
il a été très sincère dans il a expliqué
son parcours et je trouve ça très
intéressant aujourd'hui on a en france
un des journalistes professionnels qui
sont quand même qu'ils se ressemblent
énormément et et voilà les gens des
banlieues ne sont pas énormément enfin
représentée parmi les journalistes ils
arrivent sont nécessairement d'études
mais avec il s'exprime je trouve très
bien avec un sens de l'info il l'a
montré en juin dernier qui est très
intéressant autodidacte je suis désolé
mais ça fait ainsi avec le cas du
journaliste autodidacte donc pour nous
la profession a intérêt à le soutenir
quelle que soient ses idées comment
l'accident dans le code
les journalistes ne doivent pas être
traité en criminel discriminer ni mis
sur liste noire pour leur attitude
politique présumée merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous en direction est